um
but uh they are they are streaming as
well i'm sure
the links are somewhere to be found
again
at least this is the surya ganguly
um
very strong ground master 2650 plus and
many
uh
several times successful second of anon
in world championship matches
and a very strong theoretician
so i think i'm going to play something
um
a bit offbeat here
in
in the modern
php3 okay we'll go a6
oa4
sure
maybe after a4 i can go with knight f6
and
transpose to appear type of position
i had some something similar
against somebody like knightage maybe
played something similar
one thing i'm sure about is that ganguly
knows what it's doing in the opening so
he probably knows this better than i do
okay now
i'll put the knight on b4 that's one of
the idea ideas of going a6
that the
knight
and then a4 that the knight can sit on
b4 without being kicked with uh
with a3
um
now i guess i'll go e6 try and bring
break the center open
i'm not sure i love his last two moves
he gave me a target to latch on to on d5
and
a5 may just be a bit too slow
broken a rook on a4 i think is also
not
not great
um
i think i'll take the pawn
e5 i'll go 98
yeah this looks good
bishop d7 now
um
yeah here he's threatening bishop b6
um i could start calculating lines like
rook c8
bishop b6
bishop c3 queen g5 i just want to sack
the exchange since that
because i think
with his backwards development
and
weirdly developed pieces in general i
think i must have
great compensation here
and if it doesn't take the exchange i'm
gonna go ruxia the knight c4
so regardless of what it does here i
think it doesn't have it easy
okay we'll take back obviously
and there's
there's no really convenient response
here of knight f3 he had to deal with
bishop c6 queen f3 obviously there was
bishop c6
and rook h2 there was at least bishop e5
so he had a difficult choice there
uh now
after knight c4 i think he may consider
yeah that's what i thought you would do
just
chop that one off
and um
wow he continues to play very concretely
here
but i don't like bishop g5 actually i
can just go f5
activate the rook
and
um
stuff should start falling here pretty
soon
i think d6 b2
f3
they're all pretty
pretty bad weaknesses
i'll go queen b8 attacking both
d6 and b2 and also threatening rookie 7
followed by queen h2
i need to know when to let go of the
the right click that's where the
problems with the
um
problems with the um the arrows stem
from
but now i think this is
will open up the position
and he shouldn't be able to survive for
very long here i think
take an
f3 and just everything is collapsing at
this point
so surya has the problem that he
he's probably he's probably trying to
entertain his stream as well here and
as you can see in some of my games
that particular multitasking can
can go both ways
um i think rook c3 wins
there's queen f4 queen b1 knight c1
h6
looks safe
also i can yeah i can just keep it very
simple actually
just take and take
and then take again
and
you should have
next to no chances here
unless i blunder mate
oh boy
um
seriously
seriously
did i just find the only way to blunder
this
i think i may have
i think i may have
okay that is
that is annoying
knight g7 he has bishop f6
okay he has it here as well okay sure
try and flag him then
problem is i have to
keep track of so many possible checks
here it's pretty hard
oh yes queen c5
damage damn it damn it and he's pretty
fast as well
oh
is he joking
is it joking i don't know
i don't know is it joking
yes he choked
that was a nice flank
oh boy
oh boy
uh
yeah
he should have won that one